What kind of town is next?
Dad, it's
been a long time since we last visited the labyrinth city. Don't you remember? That's my uncle. Will we
meet again? [
Music] What's wrong? [Music] Mom and
Dad love you too.
[Music]
[Music] I'm sorry. It's a new
year.  If you're a low-ranking adventurer,
start from today.
Me too. Once you
become an adventurer, you won't have anything to do with that santa.
Adventurers, both high and low, go out and buy things.
Adventurers
believe in each other and cooperate.  It suits me, it's
delicious. I
know that if I let my guard down, I'll be
saved. That's what I call being careful.
[Music] [
Laughs]
Becoming an adventurer was everything I needed to live. But at that
time, I wish I had the strength.
Because I thought I might have been able to fight alongside my father and mother.